well according to this new information
it looks like the Jon Snow show might be
a lot further along in the developmental
phase than we initially thought in a new
article released only yesterday it
states Game of Thrones fans spot a major
clue hinting that the Jon Snow series is
well underway like I said HBO has yet to
confirm any of this but fans are already
thinking we're looking in the right
direction now that the New House
Targaryen series House of the Dragon has
officially debuted with rave reviews
Game of Thrones fans can't wait to see
what's next for the franchise and it
seems that the long rumor Jon Snow
sequel series might actually be
happening the hint was originally
uploaded on Reddit where one of the
users wrote Daniel West who was one of
the writers on the movie gunpowder
starring Kit Harington has this on his
profile so as we expected he's most
likely working with Mr Harrington on the
Jon Snow Sequel and we now have
confirmation that this will be a limited
series it has this listed on his agent's
website as you can see it says Daniel
West has a limited series in development
at HBO and for the record gunpowder was
also a mini-series that was made with
HBO so we know Daniel has worked with
them before alongside kit Harrington now
some of you may be wondering who the
hell is Daniel West other than someone
who wrote on a movie that starred kit
Harrington well Mr West is also his real
life best friend he's the giant glass of
water right here they actually shared a
house for over a decade this was
discussed when the rumor first came out
that West would most likely be on the
writing staff for the snow show as he
has been Kitt's writing partner and a
co-owner of their company Striker films
it was further given legitimacy when
Martin mentioned Harrington's team and a
sighting from a fan last year when Dan
and kit were on their way to a meeting
in New York city so not only are they
best friends who live together for over
a decade but they've also already worked
on a HBO miniseries and they have their
own company with one another well now
this makes a lot of sense I can
certainly understand why he will be
writing on the Jon Snow sequel series on
George RR Martin's not a Blog website he
did mention how Harrington had his own
writers and directors for the new show
him and HBO are developing if you
haven't seen it or don't remember George
R Martin said yes there is a Jon Snow
show in development and as of right now
the working name for the show is snow
there are four live-action successor
shows and development at HBO word got
out about three of them a while ago
those shows are 10 000 ships a show
about nymeria helmed by Amanda Siegel
one of the other ones is sea snake aka
the nine voyages with Bruno Heller and
then there is the Duncan egg show the
Hedge Knight or a knight of the Seven
Kingdoms who's written by Steve Conrad I
think some of these were officially
announced in other cases the news did
leak out this stuff always seems to leak
there's so many involved like writers
agents and everyone has assistance and
there's always a guy who runs the Xerox
machine so it's hard to make sure these
things stay a secret the snow show has
has been in development almost as long
as the other three but for whatever
reason it was never announced and it
never leaked until now but yes it is
true this was not an official
announcement from HBO so it seems there
was another leak I did a long interview
with James Hibbert last week for the Big
House of the Dragon Story that The
Hollywood Reporter is releasing at the
end of that interview he did ask me a
few questions about the successor shows
he said is it likely that one of the
shows is a sequel rather than a prequel
he asked and I answered no comment then
he asked is it likely that a member of
the original show is involved and again
I answer no comment and that was all but
he must have found someone more
forthcoming than me who I don't know and
I suspect I never will a good journalist
never Reveals His sources with the
amount of successor shows they already
have in development I'm sure at least
one more of them will be given the green
light
foreign
[Music]
[Music]